[Music]
last night's met gala was full of queer
stars whose looks dominated the night
little nauseas made a grand entrance
looking like a king in a gold versace
cloak with a train he then revealed a
full golden suit of armor and then
revealed his final look a fitted
jumpsuit covered in gold sparkling
jewels come on barbie let's go party
kristen stewart looked gorgeous in a
retro glam chanel look featuring bangs
another banging star megan fox looking
like a red hot pin-up girl in a lace-up
dundas gown troye sivan's simple yet
classic look turned heads with a
plunging neckline side cutouts and
cartier jewels rupaul's drag race season
13 winner simone look statuesque and
moschino riverdale star lily reinhardt
wore every us state flower on her gown
which was designed by christian cereal
kiki palmer worked the event as co-host
of vogue's live stream but the gag is
she looks like she should be on the
cover of vogue stunning ben platt looked
handsome in a vintage inspire christian
cowen
tessa thompson's arrival made jaws drop
and post star mj rodriguez showed us all
how to well
pose queer celebs also made powerful
statements with their fashion last night
including dan levy in his first
appearance at the met gala
his look paid tribute to queer art love
and visibility and paid respect to
american artist and aids activist david
wonoromich elliot page made his first
red carpet appearance since he came out
as trans wearing a valenciaga suit with
a green carnation a symbol inspired by
oscar wilde and cara de levine wore a
statement look from dior literally which
read peg the patriarchy mega popular
youtuber nikkietutorials were a
beautiful gown which paid respect to
lgbtq plus trailblazer and icon marsha p
johnson with a quote
pay it no mind
soccer star megan rapino wore a very
patriotic look with a clutch that read
in gayley trust what's an event like the
met gala without some wacky fashion one
of my favorites of the night was kim
petrus in a floral look with a 3d horse
head and if i may add she has clearly
been using man tail shampoo you say
i say yay
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos